all right yes so I'm Evan Owen I'm the
director of engineering at Co tap and my
talk tonight is on group cash and how we
used it to make to make media messaging
fast and I think I just bumped the HDMI
there we go
okay so code tap just a quick intro so
that my talk makes sense this is kind of
our x4y where whatsapp for work or a
messaging app we help you communicate
with your co-workers and we have
functionality that makes it easier to to
work we have a company directory you
don't have to swap phone numbers we have
support for multiple devices sync your
data we have native applications and
then we have integrations like
salesforce and we also allow you to send
files photos and video and so those last
three that we we wanted to do really
well we wanted it to be fast we wanted
it to feel very natural and it's pretty
hard and just to give you a bit of
background I actually come from Ruby
development I think actually I've
noticed a lot of go developers come from
a ruby background for some odd reason
and we're really shot primarily but I
had been investigating Darrow becoming
more and more interested in it around a
year and a half ago and when we ran into
this problem of wanting to send media
very quickly and efficiently I started
seeing that go might be a good way to
solve this problem so again the
challenge was how can we deliver user
media to hundreds of recipients very
quickly and make it feel fast and so we
have the ability to create groups of up
to a thousand members right now and when
you send a photo you want that message
to be delivered very quickly and we want
the the photo to show up in the right
size across maybe a poorer mobile
network and and have it
just feel as fast as possible so our
goals basically sending should feel as
fast as transmitting the data we don't
want to wait for some sort of resizing
operation to happen when the user is
sending the photo it you know obviously
we can't help you if you have a poor
Network and the clients are resizing the
the images to some extent but we want to
feel as fast as just sending the data to
the server just sort of fire-and-forget
finally we wanted the latency between
sending and receiving the message to be
as low as sending a text so when when it
says sent on your phone and the other
user may be in the same room as you sees
the message on their phone it should be
as quickly sending a text message there
shouldn't be a long you know five or 10
second delay just because we're waiting
to resize this image finally the local
time should remain constant as the
number of recipients grows so if you
have a large group we don't want that
message to take a lot longer to get
delivered and I'm sure you're kind of
starting to think about the challenges
involved in getting this done finally we
want to allow one-to-many delivery with
dozens of resolutions so you might have
a phone or a tablet or you might be on
the web with a browser window or on a
desktop app and we have all of these
apps and we want that image to be
optimized for your device so that you
can download it quickly but we don't
want to wait forever for this to happen
so in the past I've seen a lot of
patterns for image processing and we
kind of thought through these so the
easiest one is to just resize the image
or video when it gets uploaded right so
as the user is uploading it you kind of
block you do the resizing operation
maybe you store it in s3 you know the
different sizes you support it's pretty
easy to implement but it makes the
sender wait it feels awful especially if
you're on a mobile network so we load
that one out right away another pretty
common pattern is what I call
asynchronous on upload so you just take
the data and then maybe you kick off an
asynchronous worker and you resize it in
the background that's a little harder to
do but it makes the experience feel
better a surprising drawback for
messaging is that you have to wait until
the image is processed before you can
actually send the message or else the
recipient doesn't get any
and the client has to retry over and
over again until the image is actually
available so it makes the client logic a
lot harder and this didn't seem like a
great option for us either even though
this is a pretty common option
especially in the Ruby world there's
like couple gems that make this pretty
easy it just doesn't work for messaging
very well so we landed on was we got to
do this on demand we need to resize
these images as soon as the user
requests them and ideally they should be
ready as soon as they want them so I
think there's a few open-source tools to
do this I think there's one in Python
that's pretty well maintained you can
just kind of set up the server give it a
source directory of images and ask for
an image of a certain size and it'll
resize it for you and give it to you I
think it uses image magic or graphics
magic under the hood it's a little slow
a little complex and didn't do
everything we need but that's one way to
do it so if you have a thousand clients
asking for the same image its rethought
its resizing it a thousand times and so
you're wasting a lot of processing power
so we realized we needed to do these
things and I had stumbled upon good cash
around this time that I was researching
go and I just immediately realized that
this could help solve our problems so
cup cache is actually a library open
source by Google written by Brad
Fitzpatrick he actually worked at
livejournal developed memcached also
worked on open ID and it was originally
written for DL google.com and I did a
little searching realized he actually
gave a talk on this here at go SF in
September of 2013 so if any of you are
here this will be very familiar but I
doubt that it's made everybody so this
is size from one of the talks that I'm
not sure if it's the talk he gave here
but there's a lot more info there so
again memcache alternative and
interesting differences group cache is
read through only so you can't set any
values you ask for a value and if
there's a Miss you can provide it with a
value to fulfill that Miss but you can't
set or expire anything
so that changes how you might use it
it's a girl package acts as both a
server and a client to peers so it's
distributed like memcache and it
requests items from its peers and
because it's distributed and and because
it uses a consistent hash ring there are
coordinated cache fills so if you have a
lot of clients asking for the same key
even if they're hitting different peers
you actually don't run into the
Thundering Herd problem your cache fill
only happens once so this solves the
problem I mentioned earlier and finally
it actually handles replication of hot
keys across the cluster so if you have
one key that's requested more than
others and you have clients that are
hitting all of the peers in your cluster
those will actually be cached locally
there's a little bit of probability
going on and I think there's some
optimizations that are still to be made
there but it helps so kind of a
visualization for that if you have a
cluster of group cache nodes you have a
request coming in to note to the
consistent hash ring says that item is
on node 5 it'll go to node 5 and fill
that cache request if it's not in the
cache already and then returning the
item to the user again if you have
concurrent requests for a given key they
all go to node 5 and the way that group
cache is set up if all of those requests
hit node 5 all those requests simply
block and wait for that Cashville to
happen and the data is simply returned
to all the clients when it's ready so if
your imagery size takes half a second
one client requests it another client
requests at 250 milliseconds later then
the rest of the clients only have to
wait half a second because it was
already being processed and then again
finally if these clients on the edges
here also get a lot of requests for that
item
they cache it in their in their hot
cache so an interesting thing because
there in memory caches and they're
immutable you kind of have a few
restrictions on what you can cache the
man in the hot caches are LRU cache is
so least recently used
you just set a size I want a maximum of
you know maybe 512 or 1024 megabytes and
group cash just e VIX items that haven't
been accessed in a while as you reach
that limit data is cached and
transmitted using protocol buffers so
you can simply define your structs at
whatever data you want to store it will
Marshall and unmarshal into those
protocol buffers and stored in memory
and there's no set or expire once again
like I mentioned once it's filled data
is immutable so group cache is ideal for
data that doesn't change a lot or
alternatively you can adjust your keys
to represent the change in the data and
simply let the old objects fall out of
the LRU cache and if the remote can't be
reached the key is just filled locally
so if for some reason there's a network
partition or a node goes down you can
still fill that cache request on
whatever node the request comes in on so
there's an example just a little a
couple code examples you can set up the
pool just by passing in the the node
addresses for the for your own local
node and the others so you have a
consistent set of views to pop to
calculate your consistent hashing off of
and then here's where the magic happens
so you define what's called a getter
function there's an arbitrary context
struct that you can pass in we haven't
actually used that so far but I imagine
you can pass some sort of other
variables that affect how your cache
value gets generated and then obviously
the key that is being requested and then
a sync which is an interface that allows
you to pass back whatever data you're
generating to the to the requester so
obviously we're not handling errors here
very well so forgive the code but in a
simple way you simply do your operation
maybe it's a fetch request to some
external resource maybe you're doing
some some generation that takes some
time in our case we're resizing images
and processing video
etc and then you simply set the bytes
directly on the destination sink and you
pass that getter function to a new cache
group and the cache group defines the
maximum size of the LRU cache and you
give it a name and for a cluster of
group cache nodes that name needs to be
unique for the getter function that
you're passing so whenever you request
an object from this group it will
execute this function on one of your
nodes it might be the local node it
might be a peer it might already be in
cache but it's this function will be
executed only once in your cluster and
and then cached once it's fulfilled so
that's kind of an example of how you
might request data and here simply
passing a pointer to a byte slice it
allocates passes you back the data and
then you can do something with it maybe
you know most likely you're gonna serve
it to clients requesting that data and
again it'll be filled from either local
memory if it's like in hot cache or
maybe your current node is the primary
for that key or it might get it from a
peer cache or computed either locally or
on up here so next we use group cache
for media we actually decided to use a
content addressable storage so we just
calculate the hash of the data that
we're storing that way it's easy to make
sure that we have unique keys for all of
the all of the originals and we don't
need to store the original name so this
also keeps it a little bit obscure so we
keep those in cold storage and just have
the hash of the the content as the key
then we have a small group cache group
in front of those originals so that if
you have multiple clients with different
resolutions that original is in memory
and we can resize for those multiple
resolutions very quickly we don't have
to go back to the cold storage and we
actually are resizing the images in
process using OpenCV bindings that we we
wrote
with a lot of options for the resizing
and turns out image cache and sorry
image magic and and graphics magic are
pretty slow and we didn't want to shell
out so we're doing all that resizing in
process and it turned out to work very
well I could actually probably do a
presentation just on that that was
pretty fun and then we actually have a
larger group cache in front of those
resized images to allow the final image
product to basically stay in cache
longer so we have a larger LRU there and
then one of the reasons we're doing that
is because we found that a lot of
clients have the same size so we have a
lot of iPhones and a lot of desktop apps
that have the same size requirements and
so allowing those clients to take
advantage of the resized versions ended
up being very helpful so we actually
have two layers of group cache and then
finally you could just obviously put a
CDN in front of that outermost group
cache and get your images closer to your
users
you know those edge locations and say
Asia or Europe and potentially if you
wanted to do your own CDN you could put
group cache clusters in data centers and
simply allow them to be sort of regional
caches for your for your primary group
clash cluster I think that would work
pretty well but what we actually haven't
finalized implementation of the CDN but
I would just use a standard CDN for that
and just use group cast as your custom
origin so it looks something like this
we have a URL that has the hash of the
content and the size of your requesting
request comes in it gets the original
and it might be in the original cache
and then we have another layer of group
cache instances that are actually doing
the resizing through OpenCV there and so
worst case scenario it has to go all the
way back to the original but most likely
there's something in one of these two
caches either it's the resized one the
clients wanting and then it's we've seen
basically zero millisecond I think we
need to increase the resolution of those
metrics because I have no idea how fast
it is this is
one millisecond and then otherwise it's
having to do the resize which is ending
up to be pretty quick in the order of a
few hundred milliseconds for most images
so that's it what we do is basically
when we send it's just an upload we
immediately kick off a warm operation so
we request the commonly used image sizes
immediately and the client then can Rick
send the message without waiting and we
can guarantee that any recipients will
be able to retrieve the image in the
size they need they might have to wait a
little bit but for the most part the
resize will already be complete when
they go to get it
so our best case is it's just network
latency worst case is it's not in the
cache and there's a single processing
operation to to warm that cache so just
kind of a simple example of what one of
these protobufs trucks looks like it
uses property yeah straw struct tags to
define the probe of properties with the
type and the name and if you modify this
you know actually you should just use
the the proto file and generate the code
we ended up doing it ourselves because
we wanted a little bit more control over
it but and we don't have any other
languages we're using protocol buffers
with but you should probably just use
the the proto file and then here's an
interesting thing we actually added a
method to generate HTTP headers so we're
storing the content type and the last
modified date in the protocol buffer
struct and then we can simply generate
the image headers dynamically like that
and then when you go to serve it up you
just loop over those headers set your
response header and then you can very
easily set your mod time and the the
read seeker for HTTP served content and
the rest is magically handled by the
standard library in fact I wasn't aware
that serve content handled by train jizz
but we discovered when looking at the
logs that it does there were some
clients that were requesting byte ranges
and sort of content was just pulling the
image out of the cache giving the byte
range back to the client that it was
asking for and it just worked
so this ended up being a great pattern
finally this is really great so
everybody should instrument their
services there's great stats that group
cash gives you you can get the grip
stats and then the cash stats we
combined them and created an endpoint
with a bunch of JSON that we could
analyze and measure so we just expose
that locally we monitor that with sensu
and send those to graphite and then we
can kind of see how our caches are doing
what the performance is like if we have
a good hit and miss ratio that type of
thing
and then a few gotchas so we ran into a
few interesting problems one of them
early on was inconsistent hash rings so
goop cache it's not a strictly
distributed hash table so it doesn't
actually keep track of your hash table
on it on its own you kind of have to
make sure that the peer list is
consistent across your cluster so always
make sure that the local node is
included in the peer list and you have
to update those peer lists as quickly as
possible so if a node goes down make
sure that all the other nodes know about
it or else you'll start needing to
generate more michaleen one of those
requests will hit bad nose and I'll
start trying to generate those locally
and you'll have increased CPU usage
across the cluster one idea would be to
use something like console or surf if
anybody's familiar with with the hash
record console that way you can get very
very quick feedback of nodes that are
going down and update those peer lists
you can do that without reloading the
program you just set peer lists on the
group and it'll immediately update the
the hash ring family is a getter
function in consistency so when you fill
one of those cache misses you have to
make sure that it doesn't matter which
node that function is called on if for
some reason there's a difference between
running that function on node one or no
- it's indeterminate what your clients
going to get so that function should be
you can't depend on a local file being
present for instance you need to make
sure that that function can be run
anywhere across your cluster also cache
memory usage make sure you leave enough
Headroom
currently group cash actually copies the
bytes out of the local cash in order to
return it to the client so you need at
least double the cash that you have
locally in order to handle any potential
requests that are coming in so we try to
factor that into the memory usage and I
think it might even be worse than that
we need to I'm still doing some
calculations on what the memory usage
actually is and I think there's a way to
optimize that but currently it's it's
copying the bytes directly from the
local cache finally we've run into a few
dead locks so make sure you have strict
timeouts on your cache gutter functions
I think appropriate timeouts are always
a good idea for a distributed service
but this is something that we didn't
think about early on and it's really
important you don't want a distributed
system to be deadlocked and finally a
cold cluster because it's strictly read
through and there's no way to pre-warm
explicitly there's no way to set values
you want to make sure to roll your
cluster when you're doing upgrades so
that you don't have all of your nodes
cold at the same instant so depending on
your workload you might want to look at
sort of an appropriate time period
between upgrading your nodes and
hopefully this goes without saying but
because it's distributed you want to
make sure there's backwards
compatibility between the data that
you're storing so if you add values to
your protocol buffers your code will
need to handle older versions of that
until the cluster is completely till all
the data has been expired and unless
you've restarted every node there's no
way to guarantee that there's no old
data there that's it thank you very much
I'm not okay so the question was when
your peerless changes and your hash ring
is updated is that very impactful or or
does that add a lot of extra load I
think to to the cluster I'm not I don't
have any numbers for you my guess would
be if it's just a single node changing
it wouldn't be a huge change especially
if your most requested items are in the
hot cash anyway you're you're going to
be able to serve those immediately
locally I would have to do some some
experimenting on it I'm not exactly sure
if I think if your cluster is large
enough it's not gonna be much of an
issue if you just haven't like one or
two nodes yeah that would be a well two
or three notes that would be a big
difference yeah not yet we are we are
definitely working on that they're a
little incomplete right now because
they're solving the problems that we're
working on but yeah that was actually a
really interesting project and I have a
lot to say about using a Segoe but yeah
we're working on open sourcing that so
keep an eye on code apps repositories
yeah great question so sorry I'd want to
make sure I repeat the questions so did
everybody hear his question okay so the
question back here was I mentioned video
and images are single by slices video is
much larger and you can deal with
streaming video so if you actually look
at the presentation I'll go back to this
because not everybody might have gotten
it check out check out Brad's
presentation here on DL Google com
they actually cached all of the files in
deal doc Google calm in two megabyte
chunks so almost like a file system
stores data they would actually cache in
those chunks and then to form a single
file they would simply request all those
chunks from different nodes in the cache
and sort of put that together in a
single read seeker for the client and
that's similarly tower handling video we
basically are storing those chunks and
returning those chunks to the client as
it requests them so we do HLS is one of
the format's we support an HLS has
segments and so we're just returning
those segments to the client as it
requests them I think that's a great way
to handle very very large byte segments
yeah any other questions all right
thanks so much